fort à penser à un terroriste retranché
dans une bouche de métro
des passants affolés cette scène
dramatique
les futurs gardiens de la paix doivent
obligatoirement s'y préparer leur
mission localisé l'assaillant établir un
périmètre de sécurité et préparer
l'intervention des services les cdt des
tirs d'armes automatiques et vous vous
êtes équipés avec des armes
semi-automatiques
ok donc là la bonne décision
on stoppe ont fait la situation et ou
d'essayer aussi après de faire appel
c'est une formation importante qui nous
permettent d'être moins pris au dépourvu
quand on aura à faire face à ce genre de
situation sur le terrain on va être
amené à voir des choses difficiles et et
on va avoir nos émotions à gérer ce qui
va pas toujours être évident pour
devenir gardien de la paix ces élèves
doivent suivre une formation intensive
de huit mois une formation sans cesse
renouvelée pour répondre aux nouvelles
exigences du métier
la formation s'est adapté à la qualité
ce module tueries de masse et quelques
années en arrière on n'en parlait pas ou
c'étaient des s'achever réservé à des
brigades spécialisées
aujourd'hui ça touche tout le monde
aussi bien en scolarité d'élèves
dernière paie que les collègues qui sont
déjà en service
privilégiez la pratique à la théorie
c'est tout l'enjeu des nouvelles
formations de gardiens de la paix en
l'espace de dix ans les méthodes
pédagogiques ont beaucoup évolué à
l'époque fille mais on avait un tableau
blanc on expliqué au juge qu'il fallait
faire
on est plus à cette époque-là fort
heureusement on a fait faire rire on
fait des connaissances de nos élèves on
va les mettre en situation et nous
allons recentrer a fait enfin nous
permettent en fait de pouvoir
directement capté tout l'intérêt de
l'élève pour justement tout de suite la
scion dans la formation qui veulent y
aurait par exemple une année les 60
élèves de cette promotion seront
affectés en septembre prochain dans
différents commissariats dans le même
temps l'école de police de sens
continuera de tourner à plein régime
en accueillant 120 nouveaux élèves